you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess calms
tactics trainer and going to do another
group of three puzzles simply share my
thoughts along the way so in this first
one playing is white hmm
where is black vulnerable they have an
unprotected rook d8 this has my
attention
if black has a move they could maybe
throw their knight into F 3 the G pawn
is pinned but let's look at some more
direct stuff like if we take the knight
the Queen pretty much has to recapture
mmm the Queen is unprotected potentially
on e5 the rook is unprotected still on
d8 oh can we maybe exploit these
undefended pieces these are the only
points that I'm really seeing is
sensitive for Black Sea 5 d8
another thing that's actually coming to
mind is maybe something with f4 because
it is a fork but IC e takes F on son so
don't know if that's really such a good
idea one more to look into okay so this
is one candidate move but I'm not quite
sure what the follow-up would even be
Knight takes Knight Queen takes Knight
is there any great Knight move the
knight on d4 is he going to do anything
great oh oh okay so this Queen is
restricted she has to defend the night
so we could disrupt the Queen's defense
of the night by playing h4 that must be
what it is I don't I don't see in what
other way black is deficient here
yeah recognizing the defending piece and
give her a boot h for the h 5 squares
covered with the bishop I wonder what
the computer would go in for on each for
if the knight goes in here we could just
take it with the bishop or the knight
and the pawn is still on the Queen so
there's no time to take the minor piece
on f3 I thought it takes out this must
be what it is to disrupt the Queen's
position and just win a piece ok well I
had the right idea to focus in on this
square I was seeing it as the Queen
being unprotected on e5 another another
take on that could have been just seeing
that the Queen was restricted on g5 and
to try and deflect her away from the
defense of e5 ok not too bad
let's try number 2 ooh very simplified
and we're playing as black these guys
are ready to clean one move away from
queening is white okay well let me just
say right off the bat I'm thinking about
rook here because I know what white must
do one rook D to White has to play here
hmm how to stop
Hans oh you know what this is this is
something related to combining a threat
against a pond with the rook as well as
a mate threat right now these the Kings
being a knight's move apart and the rook
any rook move isn't really going to
threaten me just yet
so if we play first rook g2 and disrupt
the Kings position after rip g2 of King
f1 we play then rook to d2 threatening
mate and threatening the pond if we come
here right away
pawn push and we run the risk of losing
these guys are very far advanced you
seventy eight tough to stop that by
inserting this check rook G to King F
one rook d2 they have to stop the mate
and in the meantime we grab the pawn and
then soon thereafter the e poem so the
only other variation it considers after
rook G to suppose King goes to the
corner well I know we would do in that
case as well because well we could still
play rook to d2 threatening this pawn
and after a six they're going to get
made it King to g3 and we're threatening
rook to d1 and you can't really stop
that King could go to g1 but we're still
playing d1 for me so when the King is in
the corner and our King is on g3 it's
going to take him two moves to fend off
a mate in one threat the end well he's
just too slow to do that so this is the
important key move I believe rook G to
disrupt the Kings position in they're
going for this King F one rook d2 only
now and we simply scoop up that pawn
very important you insert that check
first what's the other the other very
creation is this one right here Chuck
King goes to the corner we come over
here you could defend that pawn but
after a king g3 soon mate they kept
remote we just grab and pick your
favorite move next rook here will be me
okay not bad let's try one more team
black okay my MA my eyes immediately
drawn to the h2 swear to disrupt the
just like in puzzle 1 the defending
piece the King in this case there's
tension on the f1 square in fact in that
first puzzle I could have viewed it as
the tension on the e5 square how to
disrupt the defender of the e5 square so
in this case there's tension on f1 how
to disrupt the Kings position
we could play Bishop here and we are
winning the exchange I know how to do
that I know how we could win the
exchange and I think that that's just
gonna be it or this one fish of h2 and
then rook takes rook is that really
enough though honestly I don't really
see how there would be something more
looking at some intersection squares
like f2 Bishop and rook I don't really
see how you could take advantage or make
use of the f2 square it's covered pretty
well three white pieces are on that
there's just one piece striking at g2
he's pretty much a non-factor in the
game the rook on h8 yeah I think that
this is another instance of a deflection
tactic Bishop h2 King takes rook takes
rook mm-hmm No
and there it's something more actually
yeah you know what it's not this as
tempting as it is Bishop h2 King takes
rook takes rook Bishop takes g5 not so
clear we're only getting a pond or one
point you know we're winning the
exchange but white is getting a pawn in
return Bishop h2 King takes Bishop rook
takes rook mm-hmm Bishop takes g5 and
this King is actually close to being
mated with Bishop to e7 yeah they're in
it black is in a tough spot with their
kings they have to be pretty careful I
think we actually take this and I should
probably retract that earlier statement
about this rook being a non-factor he's
going to be a factor yeah we could take
the rook on f1 King takes let me move
and then give this check on c4 forcing
the King back to g1 and then we have one
quiet move something that I promet we
should have mentioned much earlier much
earlier on in this puzzle there isn't a
good punch that white could be throwing
against the black King so quiet moves
may very well be in this are be
available and they are rook takes rook
King takes Bishop c4 King g1 rook f8 how
do you stop rook f1 mate
mm you don't you're getting there White
has good control over f2 this rook is
really out of place OH - is this bishop
they can't defend against the rook f1
mate
this was tempting but I'm pretty sure
rook takes King takes bishop check King
g1 and only then rock f8 to f1
Jake check Rock f8 and puzzle solved
yep that's gonna do it very tempting for
sure I'm glad I yeah yeah held off on
playing Bishop h2 right away yeah not
really working because they get this
pawn he and now we're pretty much on the
defensive tricky to win even you know
even if you tried to defend this square
with this you know there's other ways to
question the Kings position Bishop here
now what are you doing about Bishop to
g3 can't move this pawn because the
bishop would get the rook you could go
here but yeah you know it's white and
all of a sudden who's struggling and
still to bishops on the board King is in
a tough spot
you know tempting but not best best just
to grab the rook and then actually look
for me okay
not a bad group of three feel free to
leave any feedback as usual to this
video in the comment section below and
as usual I hope you got something out of
it that's all for now take care bye
you